er muss schnell her der impfstoff gegen
das virus
normalerweise dauert es mehrere jahre
einen impfstoff zu entwickeln
doch weil die zeit drängt sollen die
sechs notwendigen entwicklungsphasen nun
in ein paar monaten durchlaufen werden
[Musik]
zuerst analysieren forscher das virus
aus bestandteilen des virus und
zusatzstoffen entwickeln sie einen
möglichen impfstoff im dritten schritt
wird diese an tieren erprobt im vierten
dann an menschen
dann müssen die behörden den stoff
genehmigen bevor er letztlich in die
massenproduktion mehr als 70 impfstoff
projekte versuchen wissenschaftler
gerade so schnell wie möglich durch
diesen prozess zu schicken
einige forscher sind schon in phase 4
testen ihren impfstoff also bereits an
freiwilligen
doch experten rechnen damit dass es
mindestens ein jahr dauern wird bis eine
impfung breit verfügbar ist
forscher versuchen auf unterschiedliche
arten an einen impfstoff zu kommen
in versuchen mit lebend impfstoffen
setzen sie auf bereits bekannte harmlose
viren sogenannte vektoren ihnen wird ein
teil des erbguts des scu v2 erregers
eingeschleust die folge
sie bilden dieselben oberflächenproteine
wie das corona virus dieses verkleidete
virus keinen menschen keinen schaden
anrichten aber das immunsystem des
geimpften reagierte trotzdem darauf und
bildet antikörper nun würste der körper
wie er sich gegen das echte virus
schützen kann
andere forschen mittut impfstoffen also
mit abgetöteten teilen des corona virus
so werden auch andere impfstoffe etwa
gegen tetanus oder grippe hergestellt
allerdings könnte es mit dieser methode
schwierig werden schnell große mengen
herzustellen
die neueste entwicklung gehen basierte
impfstoffe dafür wird dem virus so
genannte rna entnommen seine genetische
bauanleitung ein damit hergestellte
impfstoff ruft im körper die bildung von
virus proteinen hervor und das
immunsystem reagiert mit antikörpern
aber es gibt noch keinen einzigen
zugelassenen impfstoff dieser art jetzt
in der krise hoffen viele es muss doch
bald mal einen impfstoff geben
doch selbst wenn er da ist heißt das
nicht dass die pandemie vorbei ist das
virus könnte notieren sich genetisch
verändern bereits erfolgreich getestete
impfstoffe könnten dann plötzlich
wirkungslos seien gegen grippeviren zb
muss jedes jahr ein neuer impfstoff
entwickelt werden und auch bereits
bekannte coronaviren neigen dazu ihre
dna zu verändern
bisher ist der chor mit 19 erreger
während seiner weltweiten verbreitung
kaum mutiert und doch bleibt ist ein
rennen gegen die zeit
je schneller ein impfstoff kommt bist du
mehr menschen können geschützt und somit
auch gerettet werden
[Musik]